hey guys Dave here with a game spot news
update Shuhei Yoshida president of
Sony's worldwide studios who said they
would like to see the next Gran Turismo
game on playstation 4 support Sony's new
PlayStation virtual reality in an
interview with Eurogamer yu Shi to
discuss gaming properties that would be
well-suited for the device which Shoni
officially branded PlayStation VR a
Tokyo Game Show 2015 in the many trial
tests we've been doing some generals
work fine he said one of those genres is
racing games so when gran turismo comes
out on ps4 I'd like to see a support
PlayStation VR although a new entry and
polyphony Digital's simulation racing
series has not been announced with a
fierce Troy yet to live in a digital
boss kazunori yamauchi who created the
Gran Turismo series previously said gran
turismo 7 will probably launch for
PlayStation 4 before 2017 in September
2015 two years after the release of Gran
Turismo 6 for the PlayStation 3
polyphony released the course editor
called gt6 traqpath editor it lets users
pick one of four themes and build a
bespoke trash around it sony has still
not confirmed when PlayStation VR will
be available playstation president
andrew house has said that the headset
will be priced as a new gaming platform
but did not provide any specific figures
so what PlayStation titles would you
like to see in VR do you think VR is the
way forward or just a passing fad let us
know in the comments section below and
for all your gaming news make sure you
stay tuned in to games.com